far away from mile beach station what  can you see and what are you hearing  this morning all of them  the atmosphere here is recently Carla's  event but of course I think a lot of  work is going on in terms of in terms of  cooperation which we've been arguing for  of course in the pollen all working for  for a long time in terms of cooperation  between intelligence services and police  that's one of my subjects as it were and  I'm sure that a lot of exchange of  information is actually taking place  right now because of course this is not  just and it's an attack in Brussels now  but it's not just an attack in Belgium  it's an attack which actually you know  really hazards all of us wherever we are  in Europe at any time and I think that's  very important